I uh just watched the entirety of your
guys's
blog era Jeopardy or whatever the [__]
it was I watched the whole thing shout
out to it's the real Jeff Eric yeah
because they have the new the new uh
podcast which is phenomenal by the way
yeah the first episode was great
um because I was like wow the blog ERA
this is my life yeah
um but that [__] was that [__] was that
was great man that was a [__] yeah it
was it was fun you won too I think you
of course everybody that's my era yeah
that's definitely my era and I mean and
we're home home turf SOB stage like
that's where I was birthed
oh it was at sobs yeah we did people if
you know you know type of thing that was
more this would be one like once it was
such a staple for New York City and the
blog era it was like we could shoot this
at my crib we could shoot this at some
stage but doing it at sobs made it feel
cooler even if no one realized we were
at sobs who to you is like the biggest
blog era
Woulda Coulda what if Charles Hamilton
by far oh my God me too no it's not even
close and I mean that and I mean that
respectfully I don't mean that in like I
remember there was that YouTube video of
Charles Hamilton backstage I think the
game was in it was Kanye there yes
Charles how much is a snapping he was uh
I was like the Green Lantern mixtape
with uh where he sampled stained outside
I'm only yeah wait am I am I confusing
that with [__]
that's Charles Hamilton right I'm sure
he's sampled stain before I could almost
guarantee it I'm confusing that or a
mood music but I mean the uh uh Joe also
sampled that um pink lava lamp was one
of my favorite
from the blog era as far as mixtapes and
if you look at Charles Hamilton
outside of just his sheer Talent he had
Jimmy ivine and Jimmy Iovine banked on
him too that's a different type of
animal when you have Jimmy Iovine that's
why he's in rooms with game and Kanye
that early
yeah it's just listen man mental health
and and prayers to him I know he still
does make music but I'm always been a
Charles Hamilton fan I don't mean that
in a way like dude me too [__] I know he
went through a lot for him I mean he was
and he was even
I think two years ahead of even where
music was about to go with the blog era
as far as
I don't like the word nerd but switching
over to that being like an actual nerdy
guy yeah yeah like yeah he referred to
himself as a blogger before like for
sure I remember uh there was a song that
he sampled
um
was it he sampled uh like the sounds of
like Windows and like I forget what it
was but he he also had that high output
that got to the point where I was just
like I don't know what's going on
anymore yeah I don't know how many
z-share [__] links this guy's [__]
dropping he had like [__] 30 mixtapes
and then he ended up beefing with Royce
over the uh the Dilla thing yeah which
was a mistake but that's being it felt
like that was the beginning of being the
quote unquote nerd and not realizing
even if you are from Harlem Cleveland
whatever like
not knowing that you're just a J dilla
fan
but not realizing how offensive that
could be to the family that you just
said your album was executive produced
by him and he passed you didn't even
doubt like you didn't even steal some
Dilla beats on the internet like you
just said you saw him in a dream and he
executive produced it and it's like that
can get really offensive to people that
were friends with him and now he's dead
like yeah he tried to make it and
Detroit is just not one of those cities
when he tried to make a comeback a few
years ago was it three or four years ago
yeah I was like oh
yeah he did um he did an interview on
HOT97 I think he had a record out with
Rita Ora was like The Comeback I think
so I could I could be wrong but I think
Rita Ora
and
he looked healthy but you could tell he
was like really really on meds like meds
had meld him out like a little too much
right and I think he just wasn't ready
for a comeback because it didn't look
like there was creativity it just looked
like he was netted the [__] out didn't
make it onto your album
I would definitely work with Charles
Hamilton depending on where his health
was as far as like a human being he's an
alien bro he's amazing and all the the
stunts that he did at that time
we would deem genius had there been a
different result and I think a lot of
the result had to do with his mental
health and the situations he was in but
all that [__] we're talking about with
the 30 albums all the internet [__] he
was doing only putting music out on his
website
um even the stunts he was doing with the
Lady Gaga [__] the Rihanna [__] even
down to the J dilla thing to some degree
if that would have figured out better
and he wasn't who he was as a person we
would be like Charles Hammond is a
genius he mastered the internet first
yes exactly yeah and it's ahead of his
time and that's what's so crazy about
the internet and artists like it just
takes like one or two things that can
change your entire Legacy from looking
like a genius to looking like an
absolute one I always say that [__]
about riff raff I'm like guys Riff Raff
was so ahead of the cloud era like he
was like the original like SoundCloud
clout rapper he was just doing what this
[__] got a world star tattoo a
bet tattoo what is he like what does he
do now he still raps he's just joked
like he looks like a [__] bro he
looks like a gnarly wrestler bro like
he's got a solid and [__] Shades and
I don't know man I'd never really paid
attention to riffraff like that I always
just loved his YouTube videos where he
would just rant like ramble because he
would just say like he's genuinely like
a [__] funny guy yeah but I never
like you know dived into Riff Raff's
music
I did DJ for him once at Ultra in Miami
please let me know how that went it was
good like how did you guys put the
setlist together can you tell me the
Green Room like so I got hit up to what
was on the rider I don't know about that
how many times did he use the bathroom I
was living in Tampa at the time and at
the time where France got a [__] uh
Iced Out shark Grill naturally yeah of
course right right right so they needed
a DJ my boy Mike Lieberman was working
with him so I had a DJing for him at
Ultra and
acted like he's performing a bunch of
girls he's got like all these cutouts of
himself and his uh husky he's got a
husky that's famous okay uh uh and then
like on the Fly he decides he wants to
DJ an EDM set like on my computer with
my library yeah so you had everything
set up no I didn't I know
you know I'm trying to like talk him
through like you know there's like intro
mix show intro versions of songs and I'm
like on the Fly trying to like hip-hop
DJ trying to teach someone who's never
DJ'd how to do an EDM set in the middle
of on during his set at home at Ultra
and it was perfect it was a [__] mess
good guy though good guy you guys still
stay in contact uh we haven't talked for
a while he's a nice guy though I like I
like where if he lived in Chandler
Arizona for a while him and his Huskies
everything does go back to Arizona I
guess they do what do you want from me
man go Sons
um but yeah no shout out to riff you
know who else was a big what if for me
was XV oh love XV yeah wow I haven't
heard that name Wichita album yeah XV
was dope executive produced by just
blaze zero Heroes
what did happen to XV uh I still follow
him he just put out some music but he
had that out he had zero Heroes which
was so fire you Priya pre-blog era and I
was talking to Jeff and Eric about this
I don't think it ever made it on camera
though there was a time when I thought
Drake and Nicholas F were a group
because at a time like yeah
even before blogs per se it was just
like there would just be websites where
they would just post a bunch of [__]
music there was like 35 Drake and
Nicholas F [__] and then comeback season
came out and I was like oh did they
split up yeah what happened to that guy
too by the way uh necklace has been
around I actually think he was doing
something in media I remember there was
a random fonte Drake record was Nicholas
f on it with him no you're talking about
uh think good thoughts that was not a
random record relax it's an incredible
record it was like a it was like a Lucy
no it was on comeback season ninth of
the beat LSI I think was supposed to
there's an elzy verse that didn't make
it I believe and I'm really nerding out
now comeback season think of thoughts
fonte Drake you have fonte on this album
I do yes which is like amazing it's
bigger than having to hold on it to me I
[__] love little brother my favorite
artist and it's not even close